all right so
tell me in your own words about the make
march matter campaign
uh the make march matter campaign is uh
it's kind of like a joint effort between
children's hospital los angeles and a
lot of
businesses and people in the community
to sort of band together and raise money
for a great great cause children's
hospital los angeles in a nutshell
that's what it is it makes sense places
that were already places that we're
already uh patronizing are given back to
the
back to the hospital
where did your interest in children's
hospital come from
um i when i was working with cbs on the
last show that i did
they have a relationship with the
hospital cbs does and we
i was recruited by the network to come
down and sort of help spread some cheer
and hand out toys to the kids and
i came down not really knowing too too
much about the hospital this is
something five six years ago something
like that
and
i was really moved at this place and
what they do for these kids and just the
you know as you walk through the halls
you see the looks on the
on the parents faces that they like feel
that their child is in good hands and
you that's nobody's faking that yeah you
know and the hospital is cutting edge
great care for the patients and their
families and they do great things for
kids who are you know
unfortunate and you know dealt a poor
hand in this game of life if you will
and it's
it's a great thing to be involved with
and i'm really really proud to lend my
name to it absolutely how did how did
that visit go for you
with the kids i mean some of them are
really i would imagine the older ones
new friends but the youngest ones you
know are just like hey this guy looks
nice
well luckily we had toys to give out so
that was
very very helpful
i mean
you know i've come in here with my
daughter before
i i know that you know as a as a parent
you had a scary moment with your with
your little one at a point um
what do you remember about like just the
feelings for i don't know helplessness
of seeing that in the parents when you
walk through a place like this with your
little one it's a scary moment
yeah of course it's very scary i mean to
have a child that has a problem is a
horrible thing but to have a place like
this that can help you with that i think
is
is a wonderful thing it's a god sense
yeah i mean the level of care here the
doctors the nurses i was telling jamie
even like a box of toys for them to play
with while they're you know in the
emergency room or whatever it is
i don't know even like the attitude of
the nursing staff and
you know they care you can see that they
care and that's a that's a great thing
you don't get that unfortunately in a
lot of hospitals adult hospitals don't
get that
children's hospital has that so that's
that's a great thing talking about the
importance of the corporate partnerships
if you you know have any uh insight into
it the importance of the corporate
partnership with
the hospital
i think it's you know
that's important there's a lot of
important elements to how we raise money
to help the hospital and i think that's
one of them there's a lot of other ones
you can go to the website and sort of
read up on how how how many different
ways there are to help which is good
yeah absolutely um i would switch gears
for a second courtney had her big
premiere for a shining veil last night
is that show uh is it in your queue i
know all you guys are very supportive of
each other it will be in the queue yes
it is i haven't seen it yet but i will
yeah i mean
what's the text chain like when you guys
have new work coming out do you share
with each other or is it just like well
you kind of find out eventually
well there's not
i would love to say this this big text
chain but on certain things we are all
in you know on a text chain but that one
that one didn't make it on the text
chain or at least maybe i've been kicked
off the text gene i don't know
you